henderson's state of the art sports
arena you know it's almost complete
that's right the dollar loan center home
of the henderson silver knights and the
indoor football league's vegas
nighthawks it's going to get busy there
hector mejia reporting live with a
construction update hector good morning
good morning guys you know once this
place opens it'll be a place for a lot
of families to enjoy hockey and other
family and community events we're right
here you know showcasing the
construction progress in fact they
recently reached a milestone where they
got approved for a permit where we don't
have to wear a heart hat check out this
massive scoreboard they're actually
still installing it and assembling it
right here and off to my right we have
some of the turf for the
football days the whole project is about
95 percent complete the arena's opening
day is almost coming up about a month
away on march 3rd with 6 000 seats an 80
million dollar project and besides
hockey and indoor football it'll be a
venue for concerts comedy shows other
sporting events most recently crews put
up the uh some signage poured some
concrete and put up landscaping outside
the henderson chamber of commerce
foundation says this facility is just
another sign of the growth down here in
henderson
you look at what lifeguard arena did for
downtown henderson on water street for
the existing businesses and then
everyone rushed to new development and
new restaurants
so they recently held a job fair here
they're looking for security guard
services ticket office clerks and
they're hoping to have up to 150 staff
on the busy game days and they're
actually having another job fair next
month that one's happening on february
12th that one is taking place over at
lifeguard arena and back out here live
you can see the gray colored walls but
they're not done quote-unquote
decorating either going to put up
something that will look somewhat like a
castle what we see at uh over at
t-mobile arena reporting live hector
mejia live local now back to you guys